after its original release in 2008
Deadspace was heralded as a fantastic
game by critics and survival horror game
fans alike and a game that would
properly iterate on Resident Evil 4's
new action-oriented survival horror with
the focus on shooting enemy Limbs and
small confined areas within the USG
ishimura a planet-cracking spaceship and
yet after two fantastic games Dead Space
3 was released in 2013 to lackluster
reviews and essentially killed the
series but 10 long years later Deadspace
is finally seeing life once again
through a remake but what type of remake
will this be is it going to pretty much
be a one for one remake A La Crash
Bandicoot insane Trilogy or are we
looking at something that will
completely reinvent the game a la
Resident Evil 2. well here is everything
we know so far about the Dead Space
remake all I mean
it was announced back on July 1st 2021
that dead space was undergoing a remake
probably thanks in part to the success
of capcom's re2 and re3 remix as well as
EA's very own Star Wars Jedi Fallen
order the game is being developed by
motive Studios and published by EA while
the announcement trailer that would
later release that month was Gamer's
first chance to see dead space in the
works the trailer actually did more than
that according to creative director
Roman Campos oriola the trailer served
as an atmospheric Benchmark for the team
and something they could use as a
reference to try and hit for the entire
game in order to create its tense
atmosphere with updated visuals EA is
utilizing their very own frostbite
engine frostbite engine was used on
various EA Star Wars games including
Star Wars squadrons also developed by
Moto Studios and Star Wars Battlefront 2
other games to use the engine include
Anthem FIFA 23 and Battlefield 2042 so
far motive Studios has only co-developed
on Star Wars Battlefront 2 and developed
Star Wars squadrons so it will
definitely be interesting to see how the
studio handles Dead Space while the
graphics of the game are getting a major
overhaul another noticeable change is in
the faces of the various characters from
Nicole getting far more detail to Isaac
looking younger less Gruff and well
totally different this has actually been
a slow Evolution though from dead space
1. in the first game there was a
different face model for Isaac then in
dead spaces 2 and 3 that face model was
combined with elements of Isaac's voice
actor Gunner Wright and now for the
Remake the face model is fully him
[Music]
gameplay and Dead Space remains fairly
faithful to the original game that means
that it's still a survival horror game
with over-the-shoulder combat you'll
collect various weapons that each have
unique strengths and weaknesses for
taking out the enemy Necromorphs and
you'll still be able to upgrade these
weapons as you progress through the game
Additionally the map is mostly faithful
to the original game with chapters and
progression being similar however while
the overall map is similar it's also
been overhauled you'll no longer be
locked off from accessing former areas
of the game and map once heading into a
new chapter instead you'll now be able
to backtrack whenever you want and find
new routes part of what this means is
that instead of taking a tram from one
section of the ship to another like in
the original Dead Space brand new areas
were added to the game with Isaac
needing to physically Traverse to get
from the end of a chapter to the
starting point of the next one and this
isn't always going to be inside of the
ship sometimes this will result in Isaac
taking a spacewalk on the whole of the
ishimura to get around to the start of a
new section and speaking of the
spacewalk while this base one has Isaac
clean to the size of the ship and then
propelling off to destination you choose
the Remake has altered the zero gravity
system to reflect how the mechanic
worked in dead spaces 2 and 3 and
changed up these sections from the
original game to better fit the ability
to move around wherever you want that
said while Isaac doesn't take a tram to
the start of a new section tramps
weren't entirely removed instead once
reaching a new section activate the tram
there and quickly return to previously
unlocked tram stations so there will
still be an element of fast travel
additionally while some of the rooms may
seem similar to what players saw in the
original game the locations of various
objects and enemies have moved around
whether that be a vent with a Necromorph
in it waiting to jump out at you certain
hallways and doorways or even the
location of various pickups like Health
ammo and guns in fact early on in the
game a character who originally gives
Isaac a Kinesis model for grappling
various objects now instead gives him a
pulse rifle a terrible gun for cutting
off limbs but what you gonna do you'll
also find doors and lockers with a
number on them and can't open them until
you get that level of security clearance
as far as we can tell gaining new levels
seems to be Story related so perhaps
this will be an added incentive for
backtracking according to Campos oriola
and creating the Remake team referenced
assets from the original game they had
full access to as opposed to just what
would come out in the final release and
were able to find various corridors
created in different ways that were
likely changed at the time due to
technical constraints and very well
could be something this new team are
restoring and bringing to life for the
Remake yet another new element of the
Dead Space remake are added side quests
in the preview we were able to play
Chapter 2 included a new side quest to
try and find Nicole which the team has
tried to make sure the player knows and
feels is a major reason Isaac is on the
mission in the first place this side
quest led to several new hologram
recordings of Nicole another aspect
worth bringing up I'm sure many many
dead space fans will be dreading is
microtransactions while Dead Space 1 and
2 were free of these they were extremely
prevalent in Dead Space 3 and considered
by many need to be a major detriment of
the game as a whole to the point where
the gameplay suffered thanks to them and
fortunately at least as of right now
there are no microtransactions in the
Dead Space remake so yes you can breathe
in a sigh of relief I think thank god
well the story of Dead Space remains
relatively intact for Dead Space remake
Isaac's girlfriend Nicole is aboard the
USG ishimura on a mining Expedition when
things go horribly wrong and Isaac along
with the small crew pick up the distress
signal and attempt to repair the ship
and rescue any survivors along with
Isaac's girlfriend before realizing the
ship is infested with horrifying
Necromorphs there are definitely changes
however to what extent we still aren't
sure dialogue in the game and various
audio logs Isaac will be able to find to
help fill in the backstory of what
happened aboard the ship to lead to its
disaster had been completely Rewritten
whether this is just flavor to try and
make the dialogue more realistic and or
more interesting or something that will
lead to Major plot changes is something
that will have to wait and see Christ
still can't believe the chief is gone
it's all Fallen apart since the captain
died the Dead Space remake will keep the
original score from the first game
written by Jason Graves while also
adding on new music composed by Trevor
gurricks meanwhile Isaac Clark will once
again be voice acted by Gunner Wright
and while he was a silent protagonist in
Dead Space 1 the Remake will instead
more closely resemble dead spaces 2 and
3 where Isaac was far more vocal in part
this is to fix the issue of Isaac being
a silent protagonist despite being
extremely qualified to deal with
engineering failures of a massive ship
considering he's the engineer assigned
to help with this situation fix the
centrifuge get the fuel running
do a full restart
but you'll need to stabilize our orbit
from there standing by while Isaac will
be more talkative that doesn't mean he's
going to be constantly yammering away
more so that he'll pitch advice when
spoken to and offer potential Solutions
the Dead Space remake is set to release
on January 27 2023 to PlayStation 5 Xbox
series X slash S and PC are you going to
be picking up the Dead Space remake and
if so what new features has you the most
excited let us know in the comments
below and join the church of unitology
today make us whole again
foreign